Nevada lawmakers are considering a bill
that would put a camera in every special
education classroom bills sponsor
Republican state senator Scott Hammond
says the issue is aimed at helping
autistic nonverbal students who can't
tell an adult when they are mistreated
in a classroom some parents have
testified that their children come home
with bruises or injuries and can't say
how they got them Hammond said the bill
tries to balance the safety and privacy
of students it limits where the camera
will be it won't be in bathrooms it
won't be any place where they will be
dressing or undressing it's certain
areas
this is Hammond's third attempt to pass
the Bill CCSD says it would cost about
14 million dollars a year